okay so continuing Jason Aaron's run on
the Incredible Hulk and picking up with
stay angry this is kind of cool but it's
also a little bit weird like it's kind
of a weird story ah it's kind of like
this this incredible whole world tour in
the sense that we get to see him face
off or team up with different people
some of which we know and some of which
we've never heard of and we'll never see
again but at the very least it does make
for something a little bit interesting
in the sense that it actually gives us
this idea of the whole Bruce Banner and
Incredible Hulk dichotomy now here's the
downside to this Jason Aaron is I mean I
need to kind of be thin you know fan
bowing out here the lid but to me Jason
Aaron it's kind of like a master of
character development like if I give
Jason Aaron a character model gives me
character or even if DC gives him a
character they said here flesh this out
he'll do an amazing job whether you love
Jane Foster when you hate Jane Foster
Thor is irrelevant the fact remains he's
done an amazing job bolstering her
character and giving her more character
death than she ever had before
some people hate the character depth she
has what she has more character depth
now than she ever did before Jason Aaron
is really really good about that kind of
thing with this whole situation with The
Incredible Hulk
we don't really get that in fact what
we're really kind of told here is that
Bruce Banner and The Incredible Hulk are
back together again their minds
basically merged in the aftermath of the
last explosion and that's it that's all
we get we don't get any huge you know
grandiose explanation is just they're
back together again now I would surmise
that this was 2012 so we're coming up on
the point where models basically
planning out the events of like in
secret Wars and the Avengers of New
Avengers and Avengers vs. x-men and
original sin and major of Ultron and so
forth all these stories are being
launched and are bringing in the idea of
event fatigue and are all going towards
the notion of all-new all-different
marvel so it was basically at a point
now where it was like time to wrap
things up with the Incredible Hulk it
kind of makes sense though because
remember the Incredible Hulk was always
a tough character to sell he was always
a tough guy to write it's like writing
Superman Superman can be really really
tough to write if you do not focus on
his interpersonal life if you don't
focus on Lois Lane if you don't focus on
you know his son Jonathan Kent he can be
a tough nut to crack in terms of
creating good stories be incredible
hulks much the same way because what
kind of a story to write with a guy who
has no limit to how strong he can get
and will always be strong enough to face
whatever force she is going against at
any particular point on will you take
the road to Jason Aaron did what is up
happening here is we pick up with the
Incredible Hulk again
kind of realizing that he and Bruce
Banner kind of merged speculating on his
own in terms of how it happened and then
ultimately goes against a group called
the Mad Dogs really just kind of this
game it's based out in Mexico you know
based out of Juarez but it brings him
into direct confrontation with the
Punisher now the reason why this matters
is because of the fact that it's the
Punisher where there's crime the
Punisher will go and the Punishers
actions are worldwide I mean more often
than not you'll find him in the United
States usually sticks there that's
really kind of his base of operations
but we've seen him travel across the
world before when he was with anti-venom
he traveled you know outside the United
States
now is necessary to save a young girl no
the fact remains that he'll leave the
u.s. and that's what it requires but
with the idea of the Punisher being here
he's just been tracking down two mad
dogs himself so it's really just by
sheer coincidence but to have them
happen to run into each other what is
I'm happening here is these Mad Dog guys
are basically you know peddling drugs
and different things like that but the
other half of this is that traditionally
speaking The Incredible Hulk persona was
always like the background persona and
Bruce Banner was always the dominant
persona what this does is it turns it on
Ted and it says The Incredible Hulk is
the dominant persona and Bruce Banner is
the recessive persona simply meaning
that the Incredible Hulk will turn back
into Bruce Banner if he gets too calm
now the reason why this is cool is
because it gives us the other side of a
coin right like whenever The Incredible
Hulk
turns back into Bruce Banner we don't
really see what goes on with the Hulk in
the mind of Bruce Banner we assume it's
around there somewhere just waiting for
its chance to come back out we know the
Incredible Hulk doesn't like Bruce
Banner he continued you know consider
something weak but we don't really see
the other side of that you know it's
like seeing the other side of the mirror
for the very first time that's what this
does it basically says look from the
aspect of the be incredible Hulk it's
the reverse of what we're used to Bruce
Banner becomes the Incredible Hulk
whenever he gets too angry The
Incredible Hulk becomes Bruce Banner
whenever he gets to calm and while it is
really simple and it is pretty basic
it's also really cool it's really kind
of interesting to get that little bit of
an explanation that little tidbit now
from here things are pretty
straightforward I mean not by anything
you know by any means a massive scenario
or situation at all not by any standard
of measurement what is it happening here
is of course the Punisher Incredible
Hulk take down these mad dog guys and
that's really it but did we end up
finding out that they were basically
transporting essentially just like a
finger just the substance you know
inside this finger it was booby-trapped
by a Bruce Banner The Incredible Hulk
goes to pick it up and gets knocked out
when he wakes up he's in Atlantis now
this is kind of a cool thing is because
the
basically just like a giant puzzle with
the Incredible Hulk unwittingly
gathering all the different pieces and
that's kind of a cool thing here he runs
into this Atlantean woman who basically
says hey look you know we're way beyond
the realm of the Submariner we exist
further down and he does in terms of the
geographical location it's really one of
like the oldest cities in Atlantis and
that's usually how it works
to be honest whatever it is at marble
wants to introduce something that has to
do with Atlantis and they want to
basically chalk it up to something Namor
didn't know about or Namor doesn't have
control over then it's like basically
saying well you know it's just a part of
Atlantis that's really old and it
doesn't exist under the jurisdiction of
Namor because we don't consider
ourselves to be part of the actual
Atlantean Kingdom it would be like if
Texas seceded from the Union that's
basically what happened with you know
with the whole Atlantean Kingdom you
know they're just different areas
different aspects that exist outside of
the control of the main Atlantean keenum
not from here we're basically given like
this sort of enemy force you know that
the Incredible Hulk has to go against
alongside this Atlantean girl the reason
why is because the Incredible Hulk
basically has an object embedded inside
of his chest kind of a rock of sorts and
the idea is that these people who are
chasing after them are trying to get it
back now of course this girl and The
Incredible Hulk are able to overcome
these guys and you know eventually make
their way up to the surface and that's
really about it I mean there's really
not much more to it than that
this isn't really one of those stories
or at least one of those little sections
of the story where there's a whole lot
of time for dialogue instead it's really
mostly just action just stuff happening
things aren't that particularly
interesting though except for the fact
that once they make it to the surface we
end up finding out that this girl is
working alongside Bruce Banner and that
the Incredible Hulk is essentially
subdued by this girl that can basically
use her sonic voice to knock out the
Incredible Hulk and then presumably this
rock is removed from its chest now the
reason why this matters is because of
the fact that the Incredible Hulk is
coming to the realization that Bruce
Banner has been laying these plans when
Bruce Banner takes level when the
Incredible Hulk gets too calm and Bruce
Banner takes over Bruce Banner has been
going to different people and outline
these different plans different steps
that are going to be taken and he's
basically using the Incredible Hulk to
achieve each and every one of these
steps now the reason why this is so cool
is because this highlights the idea of
how well Bruce Banner knows the
Incredible Hulk The Incredible Hulk
hates Banner their incredible despises
banner he'd rather be rid of their that
was the whole basis behind the two of
them being split apart in the first
place but the idea here is despite the
fact that they despised one
they know each other better than almost
anybody else could possibly know
themselves because they've just been
part of each other for so long and so
again this is really just kind of Bruce
banners using the nature of the Hulk to
achieve these individual goals for
example when the Incredible Hulk is
knocked out by this Atlantean girl he
wakes up in space now this is where
things also get kind of cool because you
know the Marvel cosmology and kind of
like the in universe history of Marvel
holds a special place in my heart you
know in turn you know at the comic book
fans it's just that way I mean it's just
I love the marble cosmic stuff I love
the in universe history in terms of all
the secret things that pop up and nobody
ever really knew about before and what
isn't happening is with the Incredible
Hulk cropping up here he basically runs
into some young kid only only for us to
find out that he's actually on a space
station outside the earth now forces
also bears with like you know frickin
laser beams attached to their heads and
so on and so forth but essentially
almost all life all the adults on this
space station are essentially dead with
the exception of a handful and so what
happens after sitting down with all
these different kids one of the guys or
at least the last remaining reader the
last remaining adult basically begin to
sort of rehash this story this is
actually really cool what we end up
finding out here is that this space
station was built by the Russians during
the Cold War of course the Cold War
basically being this idea of Russia in
the United States or I guess at the time
the USSR in the United States basically
expanding their own nuclear arsenal
trying to build as many spacecrafts as
they could in order to get into space to
be the first one to dominate the space
waste that kind of a thing but what it
also does is it brings in things like
the Kree brings in things like the
scrolls it basically tells us that
somewhere along the line Soviet
scientists came across this alien
technology and used it to build this
space station that was hidden in secret
now of course using the technology that
was available they basically made it
cloaked but this also brings in a couple
questions and we'll get to those here in
a second but what they ended up doing is
they basically stockpiled the space
station with a handful of different
things the first were of course
resources the second was by cranking out
their own super soldiers now this brings
in the history of the Russians in terms
of Marvel Comics remember with the rise
of mutants and with the formation of the
Avengers Russia countered with their own
superhero team the the winter guard but
we also ended up having them going
around and capturing people with
superhuman powers as the reason why
Professor X had saved or had rescued
Colossus from Russia because Colossus
was going to be taken and inducted into
Russia's super soldier program and
become one of their elite members which
would have
- fitted them because of his organic
steel skin but it basically makes them
almost completely indestructible and so
because of that what the soviets had
also done is they had gone to the Red
Room again the Red Room basically being
the black ops organization that was
responsible for training assassins
Natasha Romanoff the Black Widow being
the most notable they had gone to the
Red Room and they had grabbed you know
different instructors or scientists or
what-have-you and they brought them onto
the space station as well now for the
most part everything went fine but again
this begs the question of groups like
sword you know if this ship was
basically retrofitted with technology
that was 30 or 40 years old at the time
that it was used and it was designed to
make the ship invisible then surely over
the course of that 30 or 40 years shield
would have developed technology that
would allow them to see cloaked vessels
from enemy ships so on and so forth
which means that when sword was formed
the sentient world observation and
response department they would have
existed with for the purpose of
monitoring extraterrestrial threats and
being able to detect closed ships so
really thank the question why didn't
anybody know this trade station was here
it's just one of those things where not
every writer can know everything that's
ever happened in comic books and keep
track of all the continuity because
Marvel's landscape is so expansive and
half the writers don't even talk to each
other anyway so because of that we
ultimately end up finding out that when
the Soviet empire fell and gave way to
what passes for a democratic working out
Democratic regime we ended up having
this scenario where everybody who was on
this space station was effectively
forgotten they were a secret group that
nobody except some of the
highest-ranking members of the Soviet
intelligence agencies actually knew
about but with those members basically
leaving either being assassinated or
being terminated dying of old age
retiring from the physicians whatever
the case may be this space station in
conjunction with all the stuff that they
had done had more or less just kind of
been left and forgotten and so
ultimately the people up there with one
of two ways either they went insane or
they simply just started going crazy or
simply started murdering people now this
led to basically you know scientists
trying to bail out being killed by super
soldiers in the process and one of these
is really like the last remaining super
soldier kind of like this guy that just
hangs out and waits for a mission that
will never come you know waits for an
invasion that's never going to take
place because they're really you know
the purpose of the space station was
built to just wait for time when they
got orders from the USSR to begin an
invasion against like the United States
or to begin occupying the moon or
whatever the case may be but again
because of the fact that this guy's you
know it's really kind of making life
hell for these kids on the space station
and you know so on and so forth the
incredible basically
them you know they end up in some great
big huge fight a hole gets torn in the
hole of a space station and this guy
gets sucked out along with the you know
laser beam bears and spacecraft or I
guess the escape pod goes back to earth
and then we never really find out what
happens to those kids that's really
about all there is to it but from here
we basically pick up with the Incredible
Hulk landing back on earth while he's
aboard you know one of these vessels and
then more or less kind of calms down and
what-have-you and then Bruce Banner
takes back over again only pretty
incredible hope to wake up and realize
that he's in there he's been captured by
Kraven the hunter now again this is just
one of those small little segments but
as part of this overarching piece this
larger bit of the picture you know the
plants that had begun to overrun on the
space station
some of them were brought back to earth
by the Incredible Hulk which in turn
were taken by Bruce Banner in this
instance Kraven the hunter has just been
running around hunting yetis Kraven the
hunter of course being probably the
single greatest hunter and the entirety
of the Marvel Universe
once he tracks a prey he almost never
loses it in this instance you know the
reason why he has Incredible Hulk is
because it's just this notion of banners
going around and poking around kind of
drew my attention but it eventually
leads to the two of them kind of
stumbling across the Sasquatch city and
again you know the incredible Hawks
taken prisoner and this is kind of a
weird scenario because with the
Sasquatch city it basically brings back
this notion of just these small little
territories that exists around Marvel
Comics that nobody ever really deals
with or their writers makeup you know
just for the sake of a story or
different things like that for example
the Savage Land the Savage Land is
something that's never really brought up
anymore it was all the rage back in the
1980s and 1990s I mean it was everywhere
especially in the x-men books like you
do not have a story arc in the x-men
where they weren't like all the Savage
Land like we got to go to the Savage
Land you know whatever but I mean it's
still kind of a cool little thing but
the Savage Land is a place in Antarctica
that basically is just where an older
alien race that had visited earth at
some point along the line at the behest
of the beyonders began taking all these
different things dinosaurs plant life so
on and so forth and threw it in
Antarctica in this sort of giant Game
Preserve and then set it up so that the
Antarctic weather would never affect
this section of the world and that's why
when you read Marvel Comics and you read
stories about the Savage Land you'll see
all manner of critters over there I mean
you'll see dinosaurs you'll see you
clamps that are effectively extinct or
at least we would expect them to be by
the time that story took place but you
find it all in the Savage Land because
it's all just one of these little places
that exist that nobody ever really goes
to anymore the doctor remains here the
Sasquatch city is another one of these
places where you know
Sasquatch or the yetis or what-have-you
they actually exist it's almost like
this Planet of the Apes kind of scenario
but you know of course with Kraven the
hunter tracking them down you know
hunting them capturing in Porton in so
on and so forth this leads to the
Incredible Hulk you know basically kind
of a lying himself with these
sasquatches but also you know kind of
having to go against them and so on and
then eventually you know turn coding and
going against Kraven the hunter and then
just kind of being inducted into the
Sasquatch city as one of their own just
because of the fact that he protected
them you know and kept them safe so
again it's one of these cool kind of
scenarios because ultimately the
Incredible Hulk basically makes this
escape and then we end up finding him
you know waking up again in this old
shield base now again the cool thing
about this is that this is life from the
perspective of the Incredible Hulk and
that's one of the reasons why this is
really cool is because to be Incredible
Hulk when Bruce Banner takes over it
seems like all we really see or just
blips in his mind he doesn't really know
what happens now this is intentionally
designed to be that way it's really just
kind of Jason Aaron taking the idea that
when the two of them are emerged when
Bruce Banner came out the Incredible
Hulk would have no idea what happened
and that's something that's been toyed
with over the years and Marvel Comics
there's been stories where The
Incredible Hulk
remembers everything Bruce Banner is
done he basically sees the world through
the eyes of Bruce Banner but he can't
actually emerge unless Bruce Banner gets
angry and loses control because Bruce
Banner you know being controlled himself
basically keeps the Incredible Hulk
confined into the recesses of his own
mind but there are other stories like
this where when the Incredible Hulk
stops being the dominant personality and
Bruce Banner takes over that there's
nothing there you know it's just giant
chunks of his life that are gone and he
has no idea what happened hence the
reason why you see a lot of older
stories with the Incredible Hulk you
know Bruce Banner becomes the hole and
the hole just flies off the handle and
starts attacking things because from the
hoax perspective as soon as he's there
all he sees is that people are just
attacking him and he doesn't know why
and so that's one of the reasons why
being you know the Incredible Hulk
always kind of fought and so on and so
forth and so it's really kind of a
coming to terms for the Incredible Hulk
commit those with regards to Jason Aaron
because it's kind of returning the
world's perspective through the eyes of
the Incredible Hulk back to its roots
and saying hey look this is how the
Incredible Hulk essentially functions
now of course the arrival of the
Incredible Hulk in this old shield
prison basically triggered an alarm in
the Oval Office an alarm that has not
been triggered for some you know almost
almost a hundred years to be honest you
know for the terms of multiple
presidents or your president sit in your
office and suddenly an alarm goes off
that nobody ever told you about it you
know anything about well then suddenly
bells start ringing in and people start
getting sent out and so on and so forth
and so of course through investigating
you know what happened or what was going
on in this prison we end up finding out
that shield had become aware that the
Incredible Hulk that Bruce Banner was
identified as being a person down in
there now if they had sent their normal
gamut of forces you know I mean let's
say for example like the nab spot was
still available they may have been able
to take the Incredible Hulk out who
knows but they probably would have been
defeated so what they do is they call in
Ben Grimm and Wolverine really this is
kind of Jason Aaron again hitting back
at home with the idea of the traditional
Hulk mythos because the thing and
Wolverine are probably two of the
incredible Hulk's most popular enemies
right now that may change a little bit
because you know there's the Incredible
Hulk vs. Thor and then people just like
The Incredible Hulk versus like you know
these weird and kooky characters that
are like stupid popular like The
Incredible Hulk forces Franklin Richards
or like The Incredible Hulk versus
Galactus you know something crazy and
off-the-wall that incredible would
obviously lose nonetheless you know with
The Incredible Hulk basically you know
in this prison cell and realizing that
banner only ever comes out when the
Incredible Hulk stays extremely calm but
also realizing that banner is up to his
own motivations in his own you know
goings on and so on and so forth The
Incredible Hulk straddled this line
where he's basically calm he's not so
calmed that Bruce Banner will emerge
he's just angry enough that the
Incredible Hulk stays in control but
he's also just not doing anything he's
like look at banner he has his own
motivations and he's got his own plan
then if I do nothing those plans can't
come to fruition so I'll literally just
sit in one space of course you know
banner having accounted for this
basically activates or at least had
previously activated this sort of
failsafe device for the Incredible Hulk
is basically injected with what amounts
to like adrenaline so to speak where it
literally since his rage into overdrive
I mean he just starts crushing
everything around him well of course
this immediately leads to Ben Graham and
Wolverine attacking him and again that's
why this is so cool is because much like
The Incredible Hulk the example we gave
were be incredible manifest Bruce Banner
was running away from enemies or
something like that the incredible
manifests he doesn't remember anything
Bruce Banner was doing so all he sees
are enemies around him it's the same
thing with Ben Grimm and Wolverine I
mean you know as soon as they get inside
the facility the first thing they hear
is the Incredible Hulk just going aggro
and attacking everything that they that
you sees and so again it's really kind
of cool here because you know it's just
this great moment where the two of them
really try to take the Incredible Hulk
on as best they can now
and over the years the incredible Hawks
abilities his strengths and so on and so
forth have watched in Wayne they've
changed they've increased they decrease
we seen the Incredible Hulk
you know able to do everything from you
know stomp on the eastern seaboard and
shake the entirety of the east coast of
the United States all the way down to
being stronger than your average bear
you know being stronger a little bit
stronger than than the thing but nowhere
near as strong as you would expect them
to be now when we're talking about like
the weakest point of the Incredible Hulk
this be Incredible Hulk at its absolute
weakest it's still stronger than like a
vast majority of everybody and Marvel
Comics so I mean ticket for a grain of
salt when I'm talking about the
Incredible Hulk at its weakest point I
mean it's still a level of strength that
almost nobody can withstand but the fact
remains here that it's Roxton Wayne and
has changed over the years now of course
we end up having the Incredible Hulk
just taking out Wolverine and Ben Grimm
it's really not much of a conflict now
the other half of this is keep in mind
this is not a normal Incredible Hulk
facing off against them this is the
Incredible Hulk injected with what
amounts to like liquid rage and just
losing his mind so it's not like a
breaker hole but this is about as close
as we get to like savage fall because we
traditionally think of them and so again
it's really kind of cool because I
wouldn't go as far as to say that Ben
Grimm and Wolverine are fighting for
their lives but they're pretty close to
it I mean at any point they could just
run off and that would really be yeah
they would be like okay time to retreat
they could just leave but as long as
they keep fighting the Incredible Hulk
keeps dishing these blows to them now
the other half of this is remember we're
talking about a couple of guys who have
virtually limitless stamina I mean we'll
break and just keep fighting and
fighting and fighting and fighting he
can't fight as long as The Incredible
Hulk or as long as the thing but he can
fight for a pretty long time after a
while it would just kind of fall onto
the thing to be able to withstand
against the Incredible Hulk and then
after a certain amount of time the
incredible it would just win because his
strength would just keep increasing the
angrier he got but you know in the
interim he's able to basically overpower
the both of them and then just sort of
stumble off as Bruce Banner and that's
really about it and so what ends up
happening is that with the Incredible
Hulk transform back into Bruce Banner
Ben Grimm and Wolverine just kind of
leave but they just sort of walk away
and call it a day and that's really the
end of that so what is up happening is
with Bruce Banner having reimbursed
we don't find out what happens
immediately after that instead we pick
up at some point in time later on with
the Incredible Hulk strapped to a chair
and Bruce Banner basically saying look
for years we've been trying to get rid
of each other and you successfully cut
me out
we're emerged but I found a cure for the
Hulk I found a way to basically
eliminate you I found a way to get rid
of you and that's the whole thing here
is because the Incredible Hulk was
gathering up the ingredients for this
cure and didn't even know that he was
doing it as far as he knew he was just
encountering the Atlanteans in some
space station and you notice the city of
the Sasquatch people and you know this
old shield base and so on and so forth
for whether it was through these
injections or exposure to some kind of a
gas or the rock in his chest he was
gathering all these ingredients together
and didn't realize it and so in these
final moments or at least in the moments
prior to this when he had escaped the
shield bunker after fighting Wolverine
and Ben Grimm transformed back into
Bruce Banner Bruce Banner used that time
to grab the ingredients to get them all
together to engineer engineer cure strap
himself into a chair after recording a
video and this is the result of what
we're seeing he's basically saying look
you expose me to a gamma bomb and let me
die luckily my conscious mind reemerged
on yours and we were back into the same
body again but I have a cure for you I
have a way to kill you and either you're
going to stay the Incredible Hulk
forever or at some point you're going to
turn back into Bruce Banner and when you
do I will take that opportunity to kill
you so here is exactly what's going to
happen next which we do not find out in
this video if you guys are new here to
come and explain make sure you guys have
two sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you guys later peace
[Music]